Jordan well great to see you first of
all it's been 11 years since I last
interviewed you at CNN the movie just
came out right Wolf of Wall Street had
just come out your life was literally
exploding in a way you didn't really
understand of what was going to happen
but what's been your life like since
then you know the movie and it was a
special movie Leo Mar brilant fil
incredible job and uh it just became
like the greatest the biggest cult hit
one of the biggest in history and uh um
and I am grateful for that and I you
know again it was great to have that
platform and I used that to really build
my business of speaking and mentoring
around the world I've written other
books since new one now right W
investing but uh it's been a wild ride
to say the least you know but I'm more
grounded this time more grounded well
you got look a lot different you're
looking good n it was $400 million at
the box office but I think it took a lot
more elsewhere right right well you know
again the box office did great but it
was the single most pirated movie in
history that year beat Frozen it was
like I think 200 million illegal
download there is an irony about a movie
about you being the most PIR history
there's two reasons for that number one
because it was you had to be over 18 or
17 to watch it so a lot of kids download
it and also in many countries because of
all the cursing there was 506 F bombs
right you know the movie was like 50
minutes long in a lot of Islamic
countries they couldn't air a lot of it
to watch the real movie you had to watch
it online by illegally downloading so
and then it just kept going and going
and became this massive cult that was so
songs written about me in the movie just
never would have expected that but I'm
grateful for it you know the when I
watched it again the other day and I
thought I might interview you uh when I
came here it was fascinating to me to
think about when you were in your office
environment at its craziest how you
would possibly have survived today's
world today's human resource control
World today's cancel culture world you
know you think about a woman who shaved
her head in the office in the in the
room for $10,000 to get breast implants
the dwarf brought in to be thrown at a
velcro dartboard probably go to w today
right Jonah Hill you know his character
eating a goldfish which I know did
happen uh etc etc right uh when you look
at it you chuckle about what would have
happened today listen you know on some
level right A lot of the stuff that that
doesn't happen anymore it's good in some
level but on some level it's bad because
we all had a hell of a lot of fun in the
process people loved going to work there
so I think on some of this woke stuff is
taking fun out of the workplace offices
have become the most boring places on
God's Earth you used to go there and lot
of people meet their their their their
ultimate life mate 40% of people used to
meet their spouse exactly at work what
happens now I don't know how does it
even start online I guess right but I
mean it's insane you got to be so
careful nowadays right we just got very
boring I mean when you look at what your
life was like I know you've cleaned up
your
but have we just got very boring I think
that the death of everything started
with the smartphone know you used to be
a to kind of like Get Away with stuff
like it wasn't being cated photographed
and posted online social media has
turned everything into basically you
know a fishbowl and a Cess bow would you
have felt muted by a cell phone I I
think so but I can't imagine us being
any different than we were We Were Young
and Wild and you know I've watched it
slowly incrementally get you know more
Saye the world so to speak then it just
got went nuts with all the woke stuff
you know and and it was necessary some
of it some of the stuff was me too was
necessary but a lot of it it's like
anything else is wild over correction it
goes to the other side and you know it's
got to now hopefully it's starting to
make its way back to the middle so
hopefully we end up in a better version
of what we once had which was the fun
without you know some of the manness but
still some manness think is still good
when you go out and about and you're in
a restaurant or a bar or whatever is
there just a constant pressure from
people for you to be that guy like
people you know you know listen people
always come up to me and they're always
really nice and they love the movie they
love the books they love my speeches um
but a lot of them say like you know was
it really that crazy like it was worse
we were wild well you told me last time
I think it was maybe at your bachelor
party that something happened that was
so depraved you couldn't even tell me on
air yeah and even though it's on YouTube
this show is called uncensored yeah it's
so bad you I really I I got to say you
know I have a wife now for the last four
years great young beautiful amazing wife
did she know what it was thankfully when
we first met she she spoke Spanish not
English now she speaks fluent English
right so you know in the beginning she
couldn't quite figure it out but I think
now she's like I don't even want to know
but there's people still missing from my
bachelor party right there they we never
found this like know 15 years ago 25
years ago no one knows where they are
but you know it was pretty wild you said
a really interesting thing last time we
met and it was that uh you spent a lot
of time with Leo DiCaprio and apart from
the fact he'd never taken drugs and you
had to show him what is like when you're
off your head on ques uh which he
managed to replicate very convincingly
from what I hear um but it was
interesting to me you were talking about
there was a quote I read to you from
from Leo in which he had completely
accepted that there were two Jordan
borts right life before incarceration
and life after incarceration he'd
absolutely respected that Journey you'd
been on and was incredibly praiseworthy
about you as a human being which meant a
lot to you at the time did yeah but you
do you get that from everyone or are
there still a lot of people who say you
know what I watch the movie and it's
fine but there were a lot of people that
you took to the cleaners with your
criminal activity and we shouldn't be
celebrating Someone Like You Do you
still get that or not lot less after the
crisis you know 2008 2009 right I think
people have come to realize that Wall
Street is a very dangerous place and you
know it's very hard pressed to find any
firm that you know if you look at for
example any great financial crime you
know who's in the middle usually Goldman
Sachs right that's not to say they don't
do great things as well and this book
that I wrote about that like cuz Wall
Street is massively corrupt right it's
an unlevel playing field that you know
puts the little guy at a huge
disadvantage yet Wall Street still
creates massive value and it's necessary
for the economy so the question is how
do you participate how do you extract
your fair share of the value That Wall
Street creates without getting sucked
into the dark side which I was once a
part of and get your money either take
it from you quickly or slowly or just
get bled dry by engaging in things they
recommend like short-term trading the
people I know that that knew you uh in
your Heyday they said the thing about
Jordan was he would have been a
billionaire anyway without any criminal
activity you were that good as a Trader
as a guy that understood money that you
didn't ever need to cross that line and
you talk very openly and honestly about
crossing the line I'm not going to Rel
legislate all that but it was
interesting to me that people felt you
had that natural thing and your success
as a sort of motivational speaker and
advisor and you write these hugely uh
popular books and so on when you read
them you think well this guy's just
really smart right and you are well I
thank my parents for that but but but
you know I think yeah it's true and I
think the sad part is if I wouldn't have
like taken that left turn to Al
Albuquerque so to speak right I probably
would have made like 10 or 20 billion
because I would have hit the internet
bubble right and I was taking companies
public so yeah and I think one of the
lessons and it's not in this book this
is more on how to invest your money
wisely without getting sucked in but in
other books I read I speak about like
one of the biggest mistakes people make
is that yeah you could cut a few corners
and make money a little bit quicker but
the big money the real big money that
takes time and you can't cut Corners
because if you do there's some you can
cut it I mean but I mean you can't just
go if you're not giving value to people
if you're not providing some massive
value that's not going to be sustainable
to make the billions you got to be
getting value and you you can always
monetize value but you got to be giving
value somebody watching this who maybe
likes to dabble a bit in stocks and
shares and so on um maybe a bit of
property whatever it may be what is the
best way to be successful with money to
beat the system which is so skewed
against the ordinary guy so this is
really simple and this is what the book
is about so property is a separate issue
here but talking about stocks like you
know there's two parts of money okay you
got to make a certain amount of money
right and you also have to not spend
more than you make that's like sort of
the budgeting side of things right but
assuming that you make some amount of
money of some bit left over whether it's
small or large the real question is what
do you do with that money how do you put
that money to work in the markets so
that when you're ready to retire one day
you have a giant Nest Egg waiting for
you and the irony is that all the things
that you might think you should do are
what you shouldn't be doing like for
example trying to find a young winning
stock and then you know buy it and sell
it and make a big profit or time the
market or you know which sector should I
be all that stuff is just [__] it
doesn't work human beings by Nature are
terrible stock Pickers we sell when we
should buy we buy when we should sell
the simple way is you want to buy the
entire Market is an index the S&P 500
and you want to buy it and hold it and
you could start with a little bit of
money or a lot of could be $10,000 it
could be a million dollars right but the
key is you want to make little
contributions every month every quarter
right and let time do the heavy what
about okay but what about the Warren
Buffett way that's his way well his way
he actually believes he he studies
individual companies very very carefully
right and then he invests for the long
term in companies that he believes are
very well-run and have a regular cash
flow so people you know American Express
coca colola all that kind of stuff um
and he's one of the wealthiest investors
in history um is that is that really
what you're talking about where you
choose I he choose he has a portfolio of
stocks but he's in there for the very
long term that's exactly what I'm
talking about if you ask Warren Buffett
he says this exact thing I did ask him
and that's what he said buy buy the S&P
500 by all the best companies and hold
them for the long-term how many should
you have all of them that's 500 that's
right all 500 you buy it in one trade
it's the most economical tax you buy the
whole shank by all of them why but
that's not what Warren does it it on
some level it is now again he only has
like like under 20 stocks he owns right
there's there there's a difference
though there are about maybe three or
four people in the world that can beat
the S&P 500 he's one of them all these
other hedge funds and mutual funds they
don't even beat the index each year on
average they underperform the index and
after all their fees and commissions and
performance bonuses it's this what I
throw back here part of the thing of
being a investor in the stock market is
the fun of it it's a bit like betting on
horses right right you're sucking the
fun out of it with this strategy no cuz
you're saying just put it all into this
thing yeah nothing you know it's not
going to all you'll see is that one
index fluctuating in value right up and
down and probably over time it'll keep
tiing out it's very safe it's very unly
Jordan right well here's the difference
though I where's the fun I the fun is
you should set aside 5 to 10% of your
money and do exactly what you're saying
have fun speculate trade in and out but
listen you know what's fun retiring and
being freaking rich you know what sucks
it's no fun retiring and being freaking
poor okay as I always said the movie
I've been Rich I've been poor I choose
Rich every time never look back where
are you now thankfully I'm I'm wealthy
how rich are you now I don't want to say
but I thankfully do very very well what
can I guess can you guess you can guess
if I was a guessing man from when I last
saw you to now
uh 30 million okay well listen dollars
again um I do very very well am I in the
bull I don't want to say okay up down I
I don't want to say or I don't want to
say come on no I don't give me a bone I
really don't want to say I do very very
well why you say rent this is a guy that
used to boast about this it's cuz I you
know I think that as an older and wiser
person right now I don't think it's
important how much I'm worth okay what's
important is I do really really well
have everything I want in people going
to read your book The Wolf of investing
right I thoroughly enjoyed it they're
going to read this and go well all right
but how much is he worth it cuz that
will dictate whether I believe you can
go online and they have my they have my
net worth posted as $100 million I have
is what it says I have no idea how they
got that figure no idea at all but
that's what it says why it says that I
have no idea so that's three times what
I guess but I have no I'm not say if
it's right or wrong but that's what the
online says and I have no idea why are
you instructing me to go and check that
online because you're because you're
pressing me I'm just kid that's my way
out by the way but I'll tell you this
one thing no one ever accused me of is
not knowing how to make money no I've
been accused of many things but I also
know that but knowing you I also know
you would know how much you're worth to
the nearest Dollar right no actually
believe it or not um I'm not like that
that's more like my dad I was never a
counter of money I was just an earner of
money My Philosophy which I don't
suggest for most people is you know just
make so much money that you don't have
to worry about spending money that has
always been my philosophy well my
godfather who been very successful he
just said to me the only bit of advice I
give you he said is get to you money as
soon as possible there you go and I said
what do you mean he went to the extent
where you have enough money where you
can tell anybody and walk away so
someone in a job that you've got is
giving you a hard time or whatever and
I've actually acted on this um you can
just literally walk away because you
you're not relying on that thing or that
person for money to buy food in the
morning well there's and then there's
Elon Musk right he literally says you
the people to the people who he needs to
give money to X
right that's the real definition of but
I agree but listen let me just getting
back to what you said right PE the
mistake people make when they invest
because I you're right you have to have
fun and that's and specifically I say
you should speculate and I go through
how to speculate carefully have fun make
money but the bottom line is if you
think that you can take your money that
you that you save and speculate you're
going to end up okay you're not you're
going to mostly get destroyed because
this the playing field is dramatically
tipped against you when you go to a
casino right and you walk into a casino
the odds are stacked against you right
so over time you're going to lose you
might win once all but over time you
lose but you might some people enjoy
going even if they lose money but it
gets worse though because this is not
just a casino Wall Street it's a corrupt
Casino where the dice are stack or
loaded the cards are being dealt from
the bottom of the deck so it's not a
fair playing field so it's a double
whammy it's the odds are against you
naturally and then it's also stacked
against you cuz it's corrupt this
corruption there there and there's
things that are legal like short-term
high frequency trading there's inside
information all over the place there's
just you know better deals given to the
bigger investors so the answer is you
extract the value by investing in the
S&P 500 and by the way they're
constantly changing out companies so you
always have the best companies and then
you still have the fund by taking some
money that you have and go do whatever
you want you want to go and buy and sell
crypto and tokens or nfts or do you
believe in Bitcoin yes I do believe in
Bitcoin I saw Jamie Diamond saying he
just thinks it's all hot air I knowen I
respectfully just I I once thought that
too okay I did but again when you look
at something like Bitcoin it's it's like
one of those things where truly the LIE
can become the truth if enough people
say it's true but isn't it isn't it a
case if there's enough mugs out there
they all trade it with each other it
will go up well well yes but over but
you have some really smart mugs these
days you know you have some of the you
know most sophisticated people starting
to embrace it so I think most of crypto
is complet I can understand and Jamie
Diamond was saying that that you can use
cryptocurrency in a perfectly legitimate
way and it's very useful the actual
system blockchain the underlying
technology the blockchain technology
yeah that that that technology is very
useful and is widely used his argument
was more about the kind of Bitcoin stuff
which just seems to be based on a sack
of sand well on some level that's true
but you can make the same case for Fiat
currencies where they're printing
dollars just printing more dollars
anytime they see fit the one thing about
Bitcoin is a finite amount of Bitcoin
and I would agree in the early days yes
it was mostly used for fraud and
scamming and evading it's not the case
anymore there's a lot of really
sophisticated people who are buying
Bitcoin now that it's has there's efts
you know it's it's it's completely it's
you know ETFs by it's it's completely
Chang now so I think Bitcoin is legit
but the problem is all these other
shitcoins and cryptos that are worthless
and they really been they're like the
penny stocks of crypto and they're
basically been issued by people that
want to separate others from their money
and those should be avoided you
mentioned penny stocks it was that that
led you down the wrong path wasn't it
yes that stuff early on and it ended up
with you losing your
Liberty what was the worst moment for
you when it all went wrong when you look
back what was the moment you would least
want to
relive when I was asked to wear a wire
and I did and it was a friend and I see
me see in the film and I slipped him a
note because I didn't want to rap I
thought I was being a standup guy that's
that's in the movie right it's true and
I thought I was doing the right thing as
you know a man and I slipped the guy you
know saying don't incriminate yourself
right and I walked away from that saying
you know what I maintain my Integrity
because I'm not a rat and then three
months later they came back to me and
the guy ratted me out and at that moment
in time like literally I lost all faith
in humanity and I was facing 20 years in
jail they could have broken my agreement
if it was not for the FBI agent who
indicted me was a great guy he
understood and like they gave me a
second chance CU that could have
destroyed my life that was the low point
for sure that moment when I you you
think like I'm not a rat and then you
it's so that's the Jonah Hill character
but that's not true it wasn't but in in
reality it was not the Jonah Hill
character was they collapsed like three
or four people into that character right
it was someone else did you ever have
anything more to do with the one that
ratted you out you know I saw him a few
times but no relationship any
forgiveness yeah of course I forgive I
don't I not want to hold grudges and I
forgive you know and uh you know you
don't forget but you certainly can but
that was worse for you than actually
going to
prison far worse than prison itself was
waiting to go to prison the thought of
it just the uncertainty in your life
you're almost dying in slow motion you
know once you go to prison you know it
becomes almost a rebirth if you're will
to take that failure that life failure
and use it as a lesson to reinvent
yourself and and that's what I did I me
time in prison to think about stuff
there's nothing else to do for most of
the day right yeah so I did really two
things I number one is I I I thought
about stuff a lot for sure but I also
taught myself to write and I use that
time to perfect my writing so all not
perfect but just you know really become
a competent writer and that led me to
write The Wolf of Wall Street which then
launched this entirely new career so I
think the matter you know the lesson for
anyone listening is that you know
everyone everyone makes mistakes some
people make much bigger mistakes than
other right would you change anything I
mean when you look at where you've got
to now no I wouldn't the whole path up
and down and then back up would you
change it I wouldn't but that so let me
it's a complicated question so the
answer is no because it's not possible
of course if I could not have done
anything to hurt another person of
course I wish I never did that of course
I feel terrible about all that stuff and
I'm very remorseful for that okay and I
and and I've spent so many years making
up for that in countless ways but I
wouldn't change anything CU that was my
life and it happened and I've used that
as sort of like to create this life I
have now so if I could cherry pick it
and say you know I hope no one ever lost
money as my of course I do that I'm not
crazy right but you can't do that you
know you have to look back at your life
and say you know what this is what I did
I made mistakes I learned from those
mistakes and now I keep becoming a
better version of myself that's my goal
is to become a better version of myself
every day are you completely squeaky
clean now squeaky mean sober clean or
clean with the law anyway sque I'm the
cleanest person that you'll ever me you
know why because I I would have to be in
other words you know you realize that
I'm going to be scrutinized more than
anybody and in fact I was for many years
the government thought I was not paying
my fine that I had they thought I was
hiding money they looked at my [__]
with a freaking microscope right and you
know what they found after five years
zero so like waren Buffet says you could
follow anybody if a cop follows you for
300 miles they'll give you a speeding
ticket they couldn't give me one and
they follow me for for hundreds of miles
before you went into prison you
obviously had beautiful yachts and
private planes and all that kind of
thing which of those things do you still
have well I have beautiful I I fly
private often right on your own plane no
I Charter a plane which is getting
prohibitively expensive by the way which
is terrible and that's why I love the
Trump come back and lower prices for gas
would be a really good thing well come
to him yeah um I'm a fan you know not of
all things but generally speaking big
fan right um
um I would never buy a yacht again I was
so happy when the one I had sank it was
like the great I was so happy like I
didn't plan it out but when it was S I
was like yes Lloyd of London you know
right I worked at Lloyd right my first
year of my working career I and to help
a mate out I worked as on one of the
underwriting syndicates I would have
been one of those guys paying you all
that money for your yacht there you go
right I got a check for like $9 million
the day it said a few days later they
showed they're like usually we
investigate these things but you know no
one will be stupid enough to go on the
boat themselves into storm you just
here's a check and don't ever ask us to
insure you again basically they pay me
right away right so lloy was pretty good
to me so no boat but you you you Char a
private Char a private I listen I'm very
car yeah but I I do what you drive a
Mercedes Mercedes and my wife has got an
Aston Martin which one uh she's got the
truck the dbx and I have the AMG the the
the GT Turbo whatever is AMG right I'm
ask guys but cars it's interesting when
I was in my 20s and 30s I loveed cars I
just meant everything to me what car I
drive I I honestly never even now you're
Comfort I never drive even like I I'll
take a an Uber or something you know
just drive it's so much easier I could
just relax in the back seat so you know
all the a lot of the urges I had of how
I Define myself as a man so to speak
very different than the way I do today
do you ever get urges to just go and
take loads of quedes and behave
disgracefully well yeah but qus yeah not
cocaine but qus were amazing thankfully
they're legal and you can't find them
anywhere like thank God because they're
too good you know but if you have one
you know we can go after
you I do not just for the record I do
not have any guies that's the one drug
you know like and people say listen I'm
just kidding a little but a little bit
but they were amazing you're not kidding
thank God that you can't find they just
so great that you know very difficult to
resist so your desires can't be quenched
oh you know again yeah listen I I drink
a little bit here and there don't use
drugs uh the things that make sense in
your and 30s don't make sense you know
it gets a more diff to recover when you
didn't have your Liberty what was the
thing you missed most about Liberty
freedom freedom just being Lally being
able to was it were the specific things
that when you when you when you came out
what were the things you most wanted to
do again first thing I did was I ate a
cheeseburger Miss cheeseburgers
desperately right but I mean you
know it's very when you're in jail and I
was not in a terrible jail it wasn't
like I have to worry about you know
going into the shower and getting
wasn't like that okay it was it was a a
minimum security but Jail's jail you
know you have no Freedom you can't do
what you want to do and there's
something about that that can be very
suffocating now the way I got around
that was just engrossing myself and
learning at a right and that passed the
time very quickly I worked out a lot got
kept in shape but other than that just
the entire this this it's hard to
explain because you know there's
something about not having Freedom not
being able to do what you want to do
when you want to do it um is is is
suffocating and it can be very for most
people it it can break them you know for
me I was able to turn that into energy
to write and and ended up really
Reinventing an entirely new life
completely I mean it's been an amazing
reincarnation I've watched you like at
the Oxford Union and places like that
dazzling which was great by the way
great yeah and in fact they got you to
do the sell the pen thing again how many
times have you been asked to sell a pen
so many times you you ignited that part
I did it I did it
I'm not going to do it again uh but the
think about the pen it wasn't really
about the pen no you know you would do
the thing it was a very effective stunt
but ultimately it's about if you're
trying to sell something don't say this
is the best thing of all time make sure
you hone in on someone's desires to want
it and if they have a desire to want it
you're in exactly that's that's
salesmanship yeah exctly who is the best
salesman you've ever seen me that we
would know apart from youart from me
that we would know that you would know
wow you musk is
hell of a Salesman yeah I mean this he's
selling Big Dreams and you know and but
he is he a Salesman so much as just a
brilliant engineer no he's well yes he's
both I mean I don't think Elon Musk is
necessarily by salesman I think it's
someone who could sell you anything even
if the the actual thing he's selling is
not that great whereas musk I always
think there's a high quality control on
the stuff he does right whether it's the
electric vehicles whether it's uh SpaceX
and stuff this is very high many of this
stuff things fail and don't work by the
way right so but the thing with Elon
Musk is that he's able to get people
believing in him in his vision for the
future for sustained periods of time
yeah like if you go back to history of
SpaceX they were like this close to one
fail fail launch and Tesla from Tesla to
say at the same time and the same's
happening with X and I would back him to
deliver it I would never discount them
with X by the way right so I look at him
as being an amazing salesman and Buffet
by the way is another world class sales
person and communic he actually says
that what changed his life was to he
took a course on sales and persuation
yeah back then it was Dale Carnegie and
it changed his life but what does he
sell really what does he sell well in
the early days you know what he would be
without his ability to sell and persuade
the the the most successful unknown
money manager from Omaha Nebraska it was
his ability to get his message after the
to give him money to invest in Berkshire
halfway and that made him into what he
is the best salesman I think out there
for better or worse is Donald
Trump no doubt I have never seen anybody
I've never met anyone like Trump and
I've known him a long time good bad
friendly not friendly you know we fall
in and out all the time but you cannot
deny that the Showmanship the energy the
competitive streak he has But ultimately
the salesmanship he is able to
crystallize messaging and deliver it in
a way that Mass numbers of people can
understand relate to and support in a
way I haven't seen in any political
figure for a long time so I I think that
that yes it's true but he's also an
amazing marketer and promoter well is it
is it marketing marketing and
salesmanship similar there's there two
sides of sim two sides of the same
marketing is sort of like bringing so
into the next step in the process right
selling is actually closing the deal if
you look at Donald Trump I'll tell you
one thing he has that I've never seen an
uncanny sense of what the average person
needs to hear yes and it's unbelievable
you know very big themes very simple
themes repeating them again and again
again and he must be the most resilient
person I've ever met in my entire life I
would I would say he's the most thin
skinned he react to everything and
resilient and thick skinn yeah exactly
his skin is double pronged the thinnest
and the thickest of anything I've ever
seen in my life it's incredible he soaks
up stuff that would kill off any other
public figure
again I I thought when the whole thing
with with you know the whole thing with
I touched that [__] I thought that was
I thought he was done yeah and I was
baffled when he didn't even apologize
and I watched his numbers go up right he
never apologizes so and actually there's
a strength in that I mean I've demanded
he apologized sometimes but Afters when
I see people who do apologize it very
rarely does anything but make their
situation worse andless they sincerely
are sorry right and they've done
something which is clearly completely
wrong know if you were with Trump now
you'd say that what he said about that
was just locker room talk and he would
he would mean that well here's the thing
though with Trump though he was a great
president the forget the Twitter post
okay I get that you might not like AAL
communication but look at the world as
it was when he was president and look at
the world today I mean you know there
were no Wars the economy was roaring
inflation was low he got killed by Co so
to speak and the mainstream media and
this whole I mean he went through with
this whole Russian collusion nonsense
right but the country Trump's biggest
problem is this yes he gets himself in
TR biggest problem but that's also his
greatest asset you know I remember
talking to him when he was uh when he
was elected the first time and he said
my my team want me to give up Twitter
what do you think I went why would you
it just got you elected right and all
right so I'm partly to blame for
carrying on um but actually you know it
was it was that unfiltered our show is
called uncensored it was that unfilter
Ed uncensored style he had which cut
through all the normal Washington speak
people are smarter than many politicians
give them credit for and Trump you you
can hate him Al but he speaks a lot of
truth about these important issues that
matter to the average well he's he's gut
about things like I saw Jamie Diamond
defending him exactly there yeah and and
it's not because he's a massive Trump
supporter in fact he's he's financially
supported Democrats far more than
Republicans but he made the point that
you just attack all his supporters as
crazies right 7 million people
deplorables and so on you're missing the
point of why they vote for him they're
not voting for him because they love his
Tweeting or because they they like his
personal issues or whatever they're
they're supporting him because they
think he's gut feel for things like not
going to war for things like the economy
the tax reforms he brought in the reform
of NATO which they're now all paying
their dues all that kind of stuff you
know actually was very effective yeah I
think if it hadn't been for Co he'd have
been reelected quite comfortably and and
also was a huge Miss in in the way the
Republicans viewed mail and voting in
other words the mail and ballots right
they shunned it said oh no go down and
vote an election day and the Democrats
embraced it and you know you had 30 days
of voting versus one day of voting on
the Republican side so was a huge
missing tactics as well but yeah you're
right if it wasn't for KOB he most
certainly would have been can you
divorce though some of the affectedness
of trump which is undeniable with the
more outrageous stuff that comes out of
his mouth and the effect it has and I
the example the classic one being the
way he fired up that crowd on January
the 6 and then we saw the result of his
rhetoric actually manifesting itself in
an attempt to thwart democracy at the
capital I mean you can see a link when
you're the president of the United
States this matters yeah it does but you
know by I don't look at that as an
Insurrection I mean I don't know I mean
what would you call it I'll call a
moment of idiocy there was no chance
they were ever going to take over the
capital overthrow the government I think
they were trying pretty hard yeah I I I
don't I I think when people try and play
that down I'm like people died that day
you know if you look back at how many
times Hillary Clinton said the election
was raged it wasn't I mean they both do
it right and yeah he went a little bit
too far for sure but I don't look at it
was democracy was you I think the
country's stronger than that and the
Constitution is more durable than that
than that day but whatever yes it was
wrong I don't agree with what he did Ian
if he wants to win again would you like
to see him what I like to see is no war
in the Middle East I'd like to see no
war with Russia and Ukraine what I like
to see is low inflation what I'd like to
see is my taxes go down I like to see
the country energy independent and
thriving again and I'd like to see the
world a safer better place for my
children and grandchildren that's what I
want to see and I don't care about that
I'm to I'm will to to put up with the
idiotic tweets because I want the
outcomes that are most important to
myself my family and everyone I love if
Joe Biden was working for
you would you still be employing him if
he worked for me and his current
condition I I put him in a nursing home
all all due respect I mean come on I
mean I don't even really think he's
president it's like a cutout it's a
puppet I think everyone knows that I
mean this it is bit embarrassing it's
embarrassing I have friends from all
over the world they're like what what's
wrong with your country like this is the
president of the United States the most
powerful country in the world he's
walking he's like I mean you know my mom
and by not just his age my mom is 91 and
can run intellectual circles or our most
50 year olds something he was never that
sharp like because when I was a kid he
got thrown out of the elections CU he of
his plagiarism right Brit he he actually
who was the Brit that he stole the uh
yeah that's right he did yeah right he
so somehow he bounced back good for him
everyone can be resilient right but this
point in time I mean it's painfully
obvious that he's not all there anymore
he's just not so you know they should
put a real candidate up there you know
who's running things there I'm not quite
sure I suspect it's probably Obama and
that whole crew still running things and
he's just like like who's the perfect
cutout we can just have that he'll do
whatever we say and that's really what
he is and why he was put up in the last
election has the world's biggest female
movie star Margo Robbie thanked you yet
for you propelling her career she did
really yeah she did we had a really
funny uh situation where I was in
Australia with my my my my kids was
there going to school right and I pulled
into some random restaurant when was
this this is like six years ago and I
pulled into some random restaurant in
the middle of nowhere and she was we
ended up in the same restaurant in the
Gold Coast of Australia yeah and we
hogged she's like oh my God you know wow
what an outcome and she's thank you it
was the great but let me tell you this
though you know she is incredibly
talented yes this is no accident and
she's very smart because she's also
producing this stuff right through her
her company which is now doing Gang
Busters yeah I think if it wouldn't have
been the wood Wolf of Wall Street it
would have been something else when you
saw barbie grossing over a billion
you're like you know what Margot that's
on me without me this chain of events
doesn't happen yeah I I I don't really I
think she would have been a star no
matter what I think she was destined are
you a Barbie fan no no not because of
the woke stuff I just didn't like the
movie I I don't like that I I find it
hard to buy once they mention patriarchy
for the 10 oh my God I was like can you
shut up that besides that I I don't like
the whole like there's too much
suspension of disbelief of me so you
know too difficult yeah I couldn't
really watch it I agree I found it but a
lot of people I know loved it yeah I I
can't see how because a lot of women
thought great this is makes women look
great Ken's an idiot I was hoping I
would like it by the way I wasn't hop I
wasn't wanting to hate it cuz it's Margo
I love Margo I wanted to love it and
then and it started off okay and then I
was like oh my God this is just like
awful and especially at the ending with
the guitar
singer stop it want to kill myself I'm
the same I found it almost un watching
really I'm like really you know no I
think she's a brilliant actress I met
her actually in Oscar's party very
Charming uh great actress I think she's
a very talented person not just in on
screen but the production company she
set up and everything it's all great but
I thought Barbie sucked yeah it was just
it was horrendous it was bad have you
seen Leah since yeah yeah I saw him yeah
I saw him like six months ago yeah where
was in con Film Festival we ran to each
other what happens when you see each
other oh he huged me he said something
really nice goes you know what I think
we made one of the last great movies he
goes like they can't make movies like
that just can't they can't there would
be somebody from Human Resources saying
you can't have the a dwarf being thrown
at a velcro dboard you know what he said
also he goes I never saw Marty so happy
and at ease than when he was filming
that movie really he's usually much
different he was so happy and laughing
was just to watch Mario and I think on
some level the movie is an expression of
how much Marty enjoyed himself the whole
thing because I I find excuse me I find
so many movies now very boring I get
told they're brilliant yeah I sit and
try and watch them they we Hollywood
seems to have lost that ability to just
be pure entertainment one of the
exceptions top gum Maverick that was
great which was one of a great sequel to
a movie I loved but it was just pure
entertainment I went with two of my sons
in their 20s we were like punching the
air and having a great afternoon I was
like that that's what movie going should
be I think of what's wrong a couple
things number one too much Reliance on
special effects and not enough on the
story topco Maverick had an amazing
story yeah right but so much of the
stuff like you I loved Avengers and it
got crazy with all I mean with just too
much CGI and then the
woke you infused in so yeah I think
there's a real problem right now
and you know I think TV shows are much
more interesting these days than movies
I found myself watching a lot more TV
dreaming then movies and hopefully will
change you know well the pandemic
changed of viewing Pats didn't it it did
well you again we ended up watching
every single movie ever made and then
got into box sets which were great cuz
they could last like 3 4 days but you
know I went to the movies to see Top Gun
I went to theater for I went to the
theater the last time I went to the
movies was Top Gun me too because I
wanted to see it on a big screen exactly
so if it's great you'll go when you see
Davos the whole setup of Davos what do
you think of it I I think it's really
it's like the Oscars for financial
services people they get to congratulate
should happen no all going on their
private planes and preach about climate
climate change it's it's we some random
woman from the Amazon rainforest
coughing on them right and I'm like what
am I watching here it's a networking
opportunity for rich people it's you
know
self-congratulatory
nonsensical bunch of bull right and it's
so out of touch with the real problems
of the world and just you know I know
that cuz John kry went there so what
does that say right well he was jumped
about because he uses more private plays
anybody in history yeah and there is a
contradiction there because I sort of
think well the one thing we learned in
the pandemic other than to watch
everything on TV and movies was we also
learned that you don't have to be with
each other physically to have a meeting
yeah why if you're having a meeting
about things like climate change as
Kerry does do not just do it remotely
save your carbon footprint he doesn't
you can't get the statue right right you
know I crashed his wife's plane Teresa
you did yeah yeah I charted that plane
his I think they were married back then
yeah and I charted it and coming back
from I think St Martin many years ago
and uh or St Thomas and landed in a
snowstorm in farming dale Long Island
crashed the plane oh yeah yeah yeah you
nearly died on John K's wife's plane yes
yes true story that would have been a
great ending for you I know right you
got I mean how are you how do you want
to end your life eventually I mean
obviously you're a long long way from it
but you've got to go out with a bank
haven't you you know hopefully my
you know I always say my wife hates the
fly right we're in a plane sa the bounce
at hunting I'm not going to die in a
play Crash it would be way too
anti-climatic at this point I've been
through three plane crashes a yacht
sinking I mean it's not going to happen
like that so you know hopefully I'll die
many years from now asleep in my bed
with my children happy and healthy
that's my and when you do how do you
want to be
remembered is the ultimate comeback
story ultimate Redemption
story yeah that's it I mean you know I
think and I think I'm really have done a
pretty good job at that and I think it
not just that I help people you know
with this book to invest more wisely on
my sales training book to sell more
effectively or be a better entrepreneur
I think also my life into itself serves
as inspiration to people who who are who
are either you know made a mistake or
are currently down on their luck or just
struggling and you you think that you
know what how do I come back from it and
what's the single most effective bit of
advice for people that are in that
position
to get them back on
track that there's going to be typically
A specialized skill that you might have
to learn you might have to re-educate
yourself to learn something new and you
have to but you learn to write exactly
speak and everything else so there's
hard work but then there's doing hard
work that you don't like doing some hard
work people like you might like doing
something so you'll work really hard at
that embrace the stuff that you need to
embrace that maybe you don't like doing
need to train yourself to do things you
don't like doing to get the things that
you want most people skip that step they
you know like you're a famous newscast
right well you know how hard did you
work how much how do you train how much
work do you do to get to that point to
be great at interviewing people to
perfect your delivery there's work to be
done if you want to change your life and
you know you you have a certain set of
skills well guess what chances are
you're going to have to learn or perfect
a certain skill to get the outcome you
want don't just try to have the plan do
the work the hard work in the beginning
and that's the first step I think to
really changing your life I also think
just obviously the the classic never
give up is important but also everything
does pass I mean you've seen that in
your life yeah and I always say to my
kids you know and they're from 12 to 30
now but however bad things seem in the
moment short of death everything is
recoverable yeah you can survive and
thrive whatever it is do you think yeah
I do but again I I get back CU this one
missing thing thing that that that
really drives it is that you know it's
not just about hard work it's not never
give up because if you just keep doing
the same thing again and again it's
about changing your own it's about it's
something about you you might have to
change something about yourself either
learn a new skill you know build
yourself emotionally become more
resilient but you can't just be the same
person and expect different results you
have to grow yourself and that and
that's the step I think most people Miss
is they don't invest in themselves
whether it's taking the write courses
you could do it online you could do it
in person but literally learning things
that you have to know to succeed in life
and if you don't have those things
you'll keep getting batting around maybe
you'll get some mediocre results but the
greatness lies in making yourself great
you have to be great at something and
then do the hard work and then you'll
get the result you want but you've
actually met a real wolf right with a
photographer David yo so I'll I've done
many photo shoots with David in the
beginning with the real wolf ultimately
with a hybrid cuz he was getting some
flak from the animal people right so now
it's not full wolves but it's hybrid so
it's more friendly to the uh what
whatever you call the animal graes right
okay but in incredible stuff with baby
then recently I was in Bali and an old
friend of mine believe it or not he has
a house he keeps 22 wolves real wolves
in his house and it's just the more he
walks around these seven wolves and yeah
I met all surrounded by Wolves and the
wolves are not like you don't tell a
wolf to sit he'll say you know woles
wolves dance their own tune but they're
also beautiful and you they don't bite
you per se but you know you don't want
to be around them when they're hungry
did you see any similarities between you
and actual Wolf character-wise the
characters they go in packs I had my
pack my wolf pack back then right it
wasn't just me I was the leader of the I
was the alpha wolf but you know you
always have a pack of wolves and wolves
are very intelligent they always find a
way that's the thing about wolves they
always find a way and they'll kill
anything that gets in their way if it
gets in their way especially if they're
hungry great to see you John you too
let's not leave it another 12 years I
enjoy sure good to see
you